le canton a été quand même passablement
découpe et celui sur lequel j'avais
gagné en vague rose de 24 voix et donc
ce canton la était pour moi canton pour
les trois-quarts nouveau puisque c'est
un canton plus vaste et puis c'était une
affaire d'équipé puisqu'on se présenter
en binôme avec logic villaume donc ce
n'est pas une victoire personnelle c'est
une victoire de ce binôme de nos équipes
notre équipe et avec les deux
remplaçants et puis aussi de tous les
militants les habitants qui nous ont
accompagnés dans cette campagne parce
que c'était une campagne toute neuve
avec une nouvelle configuration sur un
territoire tout neuf et donc même si on
était un peu connus comme comme élu de
caen - ancienne conseillère générale on
a eu à vraiment faire une campagne de
conquête et de rencontres avec les
habitants
une élection qui accompagne la vague
bleue au niveau national qui accompagne
aussi la droite qui reste majoritaire
bien majoritaires dans ce département a
écouté tout avait été fait pour que
cette vague le pas de bleus n'est pas
lieu en fin du mois c'est sûr que dans
les têtes politiquement des citoyens la
vague bleue s'annoncer en revanche le
découpage avait été quand même savamment
étudiée pour qu'elles soient amoindris
auquel n'existe pas ce qui prouve bien
quand même que l'arroseur arrosé est une
réalité en politique et quand on se
lance dans ce genre d'affaires il faut
quand même imaginer avant tout le
découper les qu'un outil et que la
politique et repose d'abord sur les
convictions des personnes sur les idées
qu'on défend et la qualité nos actions
c'est l'union de la droite qui a permis
cette victoire notamment dans le
département
je pense que cette union elle était
attendue par tous parce que c'était la
première élection après élection
municipale en tout cas là je parle du
point de vue des caennais zetec années
qu'ils avaient une anxiété
de voir notre majorité à l'occasion de
cette élection être de moins bonne
qualité pour dire les choses avec un peu
d'élégance mais en fait on a eu à coeur
justement de pouvoir réussir ce cap et
ce message très positif a été vraiment
perçu pleinement par les canadiens et
d'ailleurs les scores sur caen sont des
scores tout à fait significatif
ce qui montre bien qu'ils attendent de
nous avant tout qu'on travaille ensemble
et pas les uns contre les autres
c'est dans ce sens que vous projeter
déjà vers les prochaines échéances les
régionales notamment en décembre il a
écouté les régionales déjà lorsqu'on
fait le tour des cinq départements de
notre grande et belle région qu'est la
normandie on voit que l'union de la
droite et du centre à porter des valeurs
qui ont été reçu cinq sur cinq par les
normandes et les normands et nous
porterons ou en tout cas moi qui suis
une réunificateur hills depuis fort
longtemps et nous porterons un projet
qui aura à coeur de maintenir les
équilibres du terril du territoire et
puis surtout de défendre quand et le
territoire de caen l'ouest de la
normandie puisque de masse notre région
sera l'ouest de la normandie et cette
union me paraît indispensable par le
projet ne parlons pas de nos officines